the project that the New York Times was
given a Pulitzer for this year of
recasting the history of the United
States in terms of slavery as the
primary narrative the 1619 project seems
to me just to be fundamentally
historically wrong it's a distortion
this isn't to say that slavery but
didn't matter it doesn't mean it's not
important it's just that if you were to
try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Martian yeah
you wouldn't start with slavery because
that wasn't really an especially unique
feature of the United States there was
slavery and it lasted much longer in
Brazil there were slavery and it was far
harsher in the Caribbean colonies of
Britain and other European states so
what's the defining characteristic
what's the thing that makes the United
States distinctive it's not slavery
[Music]
this is the Reuben report and according
to big tech I'm Dave Rubin reminder
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click that notification bell
for notifications that's what the Bell
is there for and joining me today is a
historian and senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University Neil Ferguson welcome back to
the Reuben report it's great to be back
virtually Dave I'd prefer to be back
really but hey it's the plague ear it is
the plague late year you know last time
you were on the show you flew in you
bolted from the airport we talked as
fast as we could for about an hour and a
half and then you bolted and left again
so this must be very calming for you to
be able to be at home and relaxed and at
a computer because you're a busy guy it
is very calming I had not spent three
months in one location for 20 years and
I think I had fallen victim to high
permeability and hyper globalization
where if I wasn't on a long-haul flight
at least once a week I felt there was
something wrong with my life and having
that all stop has been a real blessing
not everybody gets to work from home I'm
one of the lucky ones who can and this
has also meant more time with my family
so I think we all may have been
suffering from some kind of collective
FOMO as we flew from conference to
conference manically and covert 19
stopped the world and said you can all
get off now and for some people it's
been difficult for me it's been
literally coming home but also
metaphorically because I'm back to the
kind of life I had when I was a young
academic teaching at Oxford with little
kids and that was my life I read books I
wrote books and I read stories at night
and I'm back to that and it's great well
as most of my audience knows your wife
is the magical amazing I'll let you add
a couple other adjectives ayaan Hirsi
Ali and and you guys do have a toddler
now so
you're look at you enjoying home life
you're supposed to be a stodgy academic
and you're enjoying home life well we
have we have two sons actually I'll add
the adjectives shall I Dave yeah brave
beautiful and brilliant those are the
three things that describe my wife and
she's also a wonderful mother and our
two sons one of whom is eight the others
too are a constant source of of joy to
us and I just seeing much more of them
which is which is fascinating
I thought homeschooling was an oxymoron
and it turns out actually to work quite
well at least with some kids Thomas
who's eight has been he's really been in
some ways more engaged because he's had
greater freedom to explore and I've been
fascinated to watch him become a little
autodidact and and delve deeply into
into STEM subjects so yeah there is all
sorts of wonderful things that have have
come out of 2020 which is paradoxical
because it's been a horrible year for so
many people
well STEM subjects I thought STEM
subjects were all racist and patriarchal
and part of the oppressive machinery
that is the West or something like that
you're teaching STEM subjects to an
eight year old
well he's teaching them to himself
remember although I'm from a science
background my mother is a physicist and
so as my sister I'm the black sheep of
the family who wandered off into the
dangerous terrain of the humanities and
social sciences but Thomas is a young
man with that clear vision I think he's
identified that humanities and social
sciences are no longer the places to be
and he's been studying microbiology with
considerable zeal entirely at his own
initiative Thomas also had the best
insight about 2020 that I've yet heard
from anybody he said dad there are two
pandemics this year I said really what
what what's the other one he said well
there's there's obviously covered 19 but
there's another pandemic which is more
contagious and it's called woken 19 and
you can catch whoa code 19 from the
inter
so it's more dangerous than covert 19 I
think there's wisdom amongst the
eight-year-olds days that they give me
hope you know most people make up what
their eight year olds are saying but I
actually believe that you're anions
offspring said that you know a lot of
these a lot of the Twitter warriors was
in there pretending
yeah it's only one of his many insights
into this strange time I I do think his
generations going to surprise people if
he and his friends are anything to go by
there's a kind of healthy skepticism a
sort of South Park quality to this
generation they are very different in
their outlook as far as I can see from a
admittedly small sample from the the
generations II 20-somethings who are
currently in various stages of of
anxiety and and and woken us so I have a
suggestion which I'm sure it's
impossible to to do more than and then
speculate about because we can't poll
eight-year-olds but I think Generation T
the kids who came of age during the
Trump presidency are gonna have very
different outlooks partly because I
think they've been slightly false fared
work ideas at school and they do react
like you know Cartman and Kyle and the
kids from South Park which I find quite
encouraging because at eight I was a
kind of instinctive conservative I think
most eight-year-olds are you kind of
against change even when your parents
change the wallpaper in the the living
room you're kind of against it and I
noticed it certain familiar symptoms and
in Thomas I hope it doesn't all go away
when he becomes a teenager that would be
awful well he's gonna have to go through
a phase I hate to tell you that's that's
how it works well not necessarily
because in Britain we have boarding
schools and you just send away children
the minute they become teenagers and
they hate teachers instead of you it's
it works remarkably well that's actually
pretty clever all right so we're going
to do something
a little bit different than I would
normally do what if I was to have you on
I want to use the time with you to sort
of celebrate America and celebrate
freedom this is going to be our July 4th
special we're taping it a little bit
before July 4th but because you have an
interesting immigration story your wife
has an interesting immigration story you
are a historian and and a proud American
I thought you were the right guy to talk
to about this but before we fully get
into that am i correct you've written 14
books is that right I think it might be
15 is it 15 now yeah I think so yeah
that's a lot of books I don't even have
a question to ask I just wanted to say
it because it's an awful lot of books
and as a guy that just wrote one I just
feel like you deserve some credit on
that well the only consolation is I
think that each one is easier than the
one before so the first one is the hard
one and see you know it's not like it's
an art writing books is more like a
building cabinets it's a sort of craft
and once you've done it once the second
one is distinctly easier that's that's
the good news there are people more
prolific than I am and indeed one of my
heroes the Scottish novelist John Buchan
regarded it as a kind of wasted year if
he hadn't written the book whereas I
think my batting average is a book every
two and a half years or so so I mean I'm
not exceptionally prolific but I did use
to look around at certain universities
where I've worked and marvel at how few
books some of my colleagues were able to
write I don't know what they were doing
the rest of the time I live to write and
reading and writing are the two things
that I I'd do with the greatest facility
but thinking in the middle is the
difficult bit you do the reading and
then the heart that is the thinking once
you've figured it out the writing is a
relatively straightforward part of the
job
all right so between the personal story
the writing and a little bit of the
thinking let's let's talk about freedom
so first I just thought telling a bit
about your own personal immigration
story would be kind of interesting you
you wrote a blog about it a while back
and I think that might be a nice way to
set this whole conversation up
I've been working in the United States
since around 2002 I was transatlantic
for a while going back and forward very
regularly and it took a while before I
realized that when I was landing at
Boston Logan that felt more like coming
home than landing at Heathrow there was
a kind of gradual process I decided to
come to the United States partly out of
a sense that the action was here in my
field I was writing a lot of financial
history I'd written a history of the
Rothschilds the English by and large
like their historians to do kings and
queens prime ministers not bankers New
York cannot got what I was doing more
than the London did and I was kind of
toying with the idea of of a move to New
York University when 9/11 happened now
the Scots have a propensity to march
towards the sound of gunfire and I was
so pissed at the terrorists for
attacking New York and so determined
that they shouldn't in any way derail my
plan that in fact almost immediately
after the 9/11 attacks I I said NYU look
I'm open to an offer if you're
interested in May more or less faxed one
back the next day so I resigned from
Oxford and moved to NYU shortly after
9/11 and spent two happy years in New
York everybody should live in New York
for at least a couple of years and and
then moved to Harvard so that was the
sort of beginning of an American journey
that that was intellectually captivating
we went as you recall very quickly from
the terrorist attacks to the Iraq war
and debates about American Empire which
dominated the administration of George W
Bush now I just written a book about the
British Empire so it was natural to
start thinking about those contemporary
American issues but as I said in that
time I was transatlantic I was very much
the British historian in the United
States sort of a stock figure it was
only gradually that I began to realize
that my future was in the United States
and that if I was going to live here and
work here and not be a transatlantic
bird of passage then I should really go
from being a green card holder to
becoming a citizen and I did that almost
exactly two years ago I'm Anna I just
want to stress I'm a legal immigrant so
I jumped through the various hoops you
need to jump through held a bunch of
visas and then became a citizen and it
seemed to many of my European
contemporaries like a crazy thing to do
what their coming an American under the
trump presidency are you crazy in this
time of of disruption and my response
was well yeah part of the reason for
doing that is the recognition that
you're not signing up for a particular
president you're signing up for the
Constitution you're assigning up for the
ideals that the founders and as I've
said often to a yawn I think we
immigrants have a better appreciation of
American freedoms of the first
principles of the Republic better than
native-born Americans because we've seen
some of the alternatives now for a yarn
the alternatives were a great deal worse
if you're a girl growing up in Somalia
there aren't really too many freedoms
whatsoever I grew up in in Scotland I
grew up in the in the United Kingdom and
in many ways you could say the United
States is a sort of outgrowth of the
British Empire so there's a less obvious
contrast but there still is a contrast
and I'd been aware of it ever since I
was a kid can you talk about that
contrast I'm interested in that just
sort of from either from a Scottish or
British perspective to then come to
America and see freedom or live freedom
in it in a new way like what types of
things at a granular level did you feel
did you feel free or as a historian to
talk about certain things or was it just
more about the American ethos or what
was it there's a great questions Dave
first there's a little bit of romance to
the United States that you mustn't lose
sight of if you're growing up in Glasgow
where it rains all the time
at the romance of the the Western the
romance of American music the romance of
American literature these are powerful
attractive forces and so in classic of
the 1970s we've got a picture
spotty teenage Neil reading Jack Kerouac
watching Clint Eastwood's
and and listening to a lot of American
music I became a jazz enthusiast as a as
a teenager you could see my double bass
in the background there and that's
American music par excellence so I think
there's a romance piece to this that one
shouldn't underestimate but there's an
intellectual piece to I was steeped in
the in the values of the Scottish
enlightenment as as a boy the ideals of
Adam Smith a very individualistic
culture of 18th century Glasgow and
Edinburgh but those values had really
declined in their significance in
Scotland socialism had caught fire and
Scotland in the early 20th century I had
a great uncle who was a communist many
other people around us were diehard
labour supporters and those
enlightenment ideals of individual
responsibility of the free market they
had all really faded to the point that
the Scots hated Margaret Thatcher for
espousing those principles
now what's attractive to an immigrant
like me about the United States is that
in some places not everywhere but in
some places you can still find those
Enlightenment values and they're being
lived there their practice that that's a
very attractive feature I think it's
also true that when a Scotsman comes to
England he's constantly conscious if his
being Scottish the English are obsessed
with class the way Americans are
obsessed with race everything is about
class in England and the question is
always well which school did you go to
really and can you just do something
about that funny accent of yours so I
never really felt wholly at home in
England though I lived for many years
there in Oxford and Cambridge and and
felt much more at home as soon as I
arrived in the United States the English
believed in effortless
superiority they think you should just
sort of be born superior Americans
believe in work and they don't begrudge
success and so if you're a kind of
ambitious hard-working Scotsman this is
a more natural habitat for you than
England so for all those reasons it
didn't take long to feel at home in the
United States perhaps more at home than
I'd ever felt in in England there's
quite a lot of Scottish in the kind of
the foundations of this country and when
Alexander Hamilton suddenly became a
household name thanks to lin-manuel
Miranda's musical that was that was nice
because he'd been a kind of hero long
before he became famous again in our
family my mother's name is Hamilton the
Scots loved to say they invented the
modern world and so naturally that
includes inventing the United States or
at least its its fiscal system so for
there a whole bunch of reasons this
country was always powerfully attractive
to me I hitchhiked across America before
I went up to university at the age of 17
I actually reenacted Jack Care Act's on
the road with considerable fidelity to
the original so yeah the American Dream
has come in many forms for me and and
that's I think ultimately why becoming a
citizen was exciting the whole process
was exciting even although it had it's
it's surreal side to it did you notice a
difference on the academic side when you
were with intellectuals the way European
intellectuals would perhaps talk about
something versus the way Americans did
or different maybe a different focus or
anything like that well you know I think
there is a disappointment which I need
to admit to I came to the United States
believing that American universities
were the places where the biggest
intellects had the biggest arguments and
that that was part of the appeal of
Harvard I I admit there was this sense
that Oxford and Cambridge had been the
great universities of the 19th and 20th
century but now in the 21st century you
really wanted to be at Harvard and I
I think over time it was a slow process
I became disillusioned with the American
Academy and I found that it was becoming
less and less hospitable to the kind of
rambunctious free inquiry that motivates
me and now I've reached the point where
I look back nostalgically on the Oxford
of the 1980s where there was simply no
question of your free speech being
circumscribes on the contrary in the
1980s we kind of found ourselves
constantly pushing the boundaries of
what could be said as undergraduates we
found our professors were intellectually
an extraordinarily diverse Bunch there
were the die-hard Marxists the kind of
Eric Hobsbawm types and then there were
the high Tories the Jeremy Cato's and it
was a tremendously enriching experience
academic life in the United States
especially in the last I'll say five
years as Jonathan Haidt and others have
noted has has really really been damaged
by a culture of what used to be called
political correctness but I don't think
it that quite captures is of fundamental
intolerance of a deep in liberalism a
deep hostility to free debate and free
inquiry that is is killing the great
institutions of American academia so
yeah I mean I am as proud as it could be
of being an American but I'm at the same
time depressed by some of the trends
that I see in the country today because
they seem so at odds with the first
principles of American life is it weird
for you to see this spread across the
world at the same time because last year
when I was at Oxford and I got to speak
at Oxford Union which I still it sort of
feels like a dream that I even got to
speak there but just being there and
being around the hundreds of years of
history and walking around and you feel
this this thing that that you guys have
that we have much less of obviously
because of the breadth of history you
feel this this generation after
generation of
of tearing about knowledge and history
and all of these things and even just in
the last couple days I've seen these
articles that Oxford there are
professors pushing to have more lenient
grades for students of color and just
the rest of the sort of what I would
call intellectual rot that we've seen
across these these schools it must be
particularly painful for you to see it
happen at a place like Oxford I think so
although I sometimes get the sense that
that it's not that deep the rot in in
Oxford for example I was very pleased
that the vice-chancellor Louise
Richardson and other leaders of the
university dismissed again the calls to
tear down a statue of sessile Rhodes
that stands in oral College Cambridge I
think has been rather more inclined to
appease these forces of iconoclasm it is
iconoclasm the tearing down of statues
and I know that I'm a conservative when
I see statues being torn down and a
little part of me winces it doesn't
really much matter who the statue is I
prefer statues to be built and and I
think Oxford has has held the line there
thus far but as is always the case there
are elements within any academic society
that let's see opportunities in the
ideologies of workers see ways in which
they can advance their own careers by
championing these outlandish and
illiberal ideas the the great danger is
that it becomes a norm that a university
should be intellectually homogeneous
that that we should pursue every kind of
diversity except intellectual and
ideological diversity and and I worry
that eventually what what has been
happening at American universities will
overcome the healthier forces in Oxford
and Cambridge that's not to say that
that could we couldn't do more at these
universities to make them
tract of two and appealing to people
from minority communities and from the
white working class which is notably
underrepresented at these places but the
mistake that's always made in these
debates is to think that the problem
lies with the universities rather than
with the systems of education that
simply discourage students or make them
unable to apply it to elite institutions
I've always said I believe passionately
an educational opportunity and the
social mobility that it creates my
parents were the first in their families
to go to university and what I see in
the United States and in the UK are
failing schools that don't allow
talented young people whether they're
from minority communities or from the
working class to get anywhere close to
applying to elite universities that's
what we need to fix and there are lots
of ways of doing it but one doesn't hear
those discussed so I know we could spend
you know eight hours days dissecting
woke nests and and the rest of it but I
want to ship from it a little bit but I
just have one other question on the woke
things since we've treaded into those
waters as a conservative academic you
were obviously and we talked about a
little bit about this last time on the
outside of what most sort of academic
circles you know sort of think is
acceptable even even in historical in
history department do you think that
conservatives have a better defense
against woke miss than liberals so for
example John hate who I've had on the
show and and many of the other academics
that you know that that I've talked to
that come from the more liberal side I
sense that they although they're making
good arguments I don't think they have
good defenses against this because of
the sort of openness of liberalism that
it's being used against itself and I do
sense that conservatism as a worldview
or as a philosophical lens does have
some protections that liberalism doesn't
do you agree with that well it's true
that that we wouldn't be in quite this
situation if it hadn't been for liberal
professors giving jobs to progressive
professors who then gave jobs to
Marxists and cultural Marxists I mean
conservative academic conservative
professor these are becoming oxymorons
because there are so few conservatives
left and the American Academy I mean
that the figures are clear it's not like
this is an old problem that we've always
had over time the ratio of registered
Democrats to Republicans has risen
steadily to the point that you can't
calculate it in some departments because
there are zero Republicans and I think
that that trend broadly is explicable
because liberals felt that they should
hire people to the left of them under
estimating the extent to which those
people would fundamentally differ on the
the principles of say the project of
historical scholarship it is not the
goal of a history department to impose
on the past the ideals of the
progressives of 2020 that's the ultimate
condescension to the Past conservatives
have understood better I think the
dangers and and the tragedy has been
that conservatives have been poorly
organized I mean the extinction of
conservatives in say history departments
isn't just the fault of liberals hiring
progressives it's also that the
conservatives did poorly when it came to
the most basic organization that has to
happen in academia the patronage
networks but getting your students into
good positions I don't think
conservatives were very good at that
my conservative mentors were wonderful
intellectuals people like Norman stone
but Norman would not be remembered I
think for his his organizational skills
for his writing certainly but but
definitely not for his deafness academic
politics so it's partly I think because
conservatives were rather too busy
writing books and perhaps occasionally
drinking bottles of wine and not working
hard enough at the committee stages to
make sure that the right candidates got
hired it's interesting and I think it's
this that right there almost explains
everything happening in the world right
now that we let all these
out after watching academia sorta
crumble and and here we are but but
shifting from that from from a
historians perspective what do you think
that the average American should know
about the history of America that we
don't know or that we under appreciate
because you know we seem to live in a
time where we're we're erasing our own
history and we're taking down monuments
and we're you know destroying the names
of people that were flawed but that were
just people of their time well I think
the the challenge here is that history
is not it's not monochrome the history
of any Great Society or state can't be
told as a eulogy Norton or as a kind of
criminal indictment and the good
historian of the United States or for
that matter of the United Kingdom
acknowledges that there are debits as
well as credits that there is there's
shadow those dark sides to the story as
well as bright sides and this is a
challenge that I didn't think was
difficult when I was writing early in my
career I wrote a history of the British
Empire which included a chapter on the
American Revolution and the book sets
out very plainly there are many stains
on the history of the British Empire
including of course the the central role
of slavery in the in the southern
colonies that became the southern states
of the United States but the point of
that book and I make the same argument
about the history of the United States
is that the the benefits outweighed the
costs that the successes were more
important ultimately than the failures
the project that the New York Times was
given a Pulitzer for this year of
recasting the history of the United
States in terms of slavery as the
primary narrative the 1619 project seems
to me just to be fundamentally
historically wrong it's a distortion
this isn't to say that slavery had
didn't matter it doesn't mean it's not
important it's just that if you were to
try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Martian yeah
you wouldn't start
with slavery because that wasn't really
an especially unique feature of the
United States there was slavery in it
lasted much longer in Brazil there were
slavery and it was far harsher in the
Caribbean colonies of Britain and other
European states so what's the defining
characteristic what's the thing that
makes the United States distinctive it's
not slavery any more than if you looked
at Western civilization broadly it would
be true to say that imperialism's the
defining characteristic everybody did
Empire just as slavery goes way back
before 1619 all the way to ancient times
and by the way still exists there is
still slavery there are slave markets
where people are sold there are slave
economies which rely on slave labor
today so it can't really be true to say
that the interesting thing the thing you
really need to know about the United
States is slavery but the interesting
thing about the United States is that it
represented an experiment in governance
a radical experiment based on ideas from
the Enlightenment and earlier ideas from
the Protestant Reformation it's fair to
say and this produced an extraordinary
Constitution which has stood up to all
the stresses and strains of of history
since the late 18th century and
understanding that peculiar Constitution
that very distinctive document with its
separation of powers and its careful
preservations of individually but that
should be your top priority if you're
studying American history not to the
exclusion of the bad stuff there's
plenty of bad stuff that we need to
study but I don't think we should be
teaching young Americans from Howard
Zinn's people's history of the united
states in which the negatives are
constantly emphasized over the positives
that just seems to me to miss the point
of the American story completely are you
worried that the
ordinary pressures that were facing
right now between a pandemic between
riots and protests between you know
polarization that really is is off the
charts and then throw in social media
which is just gas on the flame are you
worried that those pressures could snap
that project in a way that it hasn't
been snapped before or certainly in the
last 100 years let's say they've let me
give you a somewhat surprising answer
that question I'd be worried if we
weren't worried one of the things about
this country that's very distinctive is
that we're always worried that the
Republic's gonna end we're always kind
of threatening about about the coming
tyranny the impending Civil War and and
thus far there's been one civil war and
no dictatorships and that's kind of
encouraging I think that's partly
because we worry about is and I think
it's a healthy feature of American life
also to expect decline people have been
predicting the decline of the United
States throughout my life it was a
preoccupation of Henry Kissinger whose
biography I'm in the midst of of writing
in the 1970s it seems as if the United
States was being torn apart by Vietnam
torn apart by its racial divisions torn
apart by a president who had violated
his his oath of office all of that we've
seen before and I I think it's part of
the way the United States works that
we're always expecting that
disintegration of the Republic and the
descent into civil war and I think we'll
have to start being nervous if we stop
worrying about that stuff but as long as
we have my old friend Andrew Sullivan so
fretful about the coming Trump tyranny
that he doesn't quite spot the tyranny
of the left until it's right up behind
him I mean that that's kind of the
predicament that I think a lot of
liberals and conservatives find
themselves in that they were so
indignant and dismayed by Trump back in
2016 that they slightly underestimated
the the rather more operationally
worrying tyrannical tendencies of the
radical left so yeah I think we
we should keep worrying about this stuff
and as long as we're worrying about it
we'll probably be okay yeah does it also
strike you as as odd or maybe obvious
relative to social media that when
something happens here that it suddenly
happens everywhere I mean we've all seen
the the videos now of literally police
officers in London being hunted down by
mobs that has nothing to do in any
concrete sense with what happened to
George Floyd and yet
it seems like if there's an incident
here it's now exported everywhere I
think future historians will wonder why
it was that in the midst of a pandemic
which is far from over Americans decided
to have a debate about police violence
towards African Americans not not to say
that that's not an important issue to
think about but it seems an odd time to
have that debate and to start debates
about defunding the police when we
should really be wondering what went
wrong at the Department of Health and
Human Services and CDC when they ought
to have taken far better and earlier
action to contain the contagion
there's something strange it's a non
sequitur that in the midst of this
massive public health crisis which has
killed nearly a hundred and twenty
thousand Americans and will probably
kill another 120,000 before the end of
the year were having this this debate
but the second point I'd make is that
the Internet has created a new kind of
contagion as I said earlier quoting my
son there are two pandemics and the
second pandemic in fact predates the
murder of of George Floyd because it's a
pandemic of protests that you could
actually see in Hong Kong in Santiago in
Barcelona in cities like Beirut last
year and what is interesting to me is
that the mode of protest is consistently
the same the content varies from place
to place but this quality of protest to
go viral styles of protests to be cop
copied from Hong Kong
- Minneapolis is really interesting I
mean historically the police had better
communications than demonstrators for
most of the second half of the 20th
century that the police and
walkie-talkies and the demonstrators
were lucky if they had mega phones but
the smartphone has changed that and it's
allowed protesters to really organize
these a setlist networks where there is
no obvious leader and actually if
superior comes to the police so I think
what's interesting about the great
eruption of protests that we've seen in
the last month in the United States is
that actually it's in terms of its form
quite a close copy of the Hong Kong
protests of last year it's just that the
contents difference and I think you can
keep these sorts of protest waves going
as long as people are viral video as
well as sort of tips and organizing a
protest that they can simply download
and apply to their in context
that I think is the really interesting
feature it's not the content of the
protests that's the same as in previous
waves of revolution here it's just the
form of protest that's the same the
content varies from place to place yeah
it's interesting so you're saying you're
not worried because we worry and then on
the other hand there is this other
pathogen or virus or whatever you want
to call it that really does make this
something that we've just never dealt
with before I think we dealt with the
revolutionary crowd before it's just
like the revolutionary crowd didn't have
smartphones before I was fascinated by
the way in which the Hong Kong
protesters outsmarted the police there
last year partly by constantly changing
the form of the protest partly by not
having leaders that you could just round
up partly by shifting away from violence
when violence was alienating local
people and I think we saw something of
that happen because in June there was a
period early on when the protests were
quite violent and there was looting and
that actually was quite unhelpful to the
protesters cause and then you saw a
shift in the style of protest in many in
many places so this shape-shifting
quality of of the crowd with
smartphones is an interesting thing to
observe I don't think it's necessarily a
disastrous phenomenon because in some
contexts these protests achieve
successful outcomes you know crowds
aren't always bad
there are even occasions when you can
justify pulling down a statue think New
York 1776 but my my sense is that on the
specific issue that is being addressed
in the United States today which has to
do with changing the way the police
operate there is a big disconnect
between what is said by protesters and
and indeed by black lives matter and
what we know from from good social
science the real the real problem is and
and I do think it's difficult for a
crowd to read social science and arrive
at actionable policy recommendations
that tends not to happen is is that the
biggest danger that we have going right
now that there's a certain set of people
that it doesn't matter what the social
science says it doesn't matter what the
facts say that their ideology overrides
all of that so this sort of goes back to
what I was saying about our liberal
academic friends it's like you guys can
make sound arguments all day long that's
that's great
I love it I'll do it all day with you
but that doesn't actually address the
problem because there's something else
going on here that can't be rationalized
out of rights and I think you know the
case of Roland Farr illustrates many of
the predicaments that we find ourselves
in today Roland's who wrote some
pioneering papers as a Harvard economist
in 2016
published an extraordinary important
study showing that while the police did
disproportionately shove push and
otherwise manhandle african-americans
compared with white suspects they did
not disproportionately shoot African
Americans and and that finding was an
extremely important one since
at the core of blacklivesmatter was a
claim that the police disproportionately
used lethal violence against black
people and it turns out not to be true
but what became of Roland after that
publication he knew there would be
blowback and there was but what actually
happened was not at all what he or I or
his friends had expected what happened
was that he was accused of sexual
harassment by a former employee quite
incidentally and then found himself
sucked into a title 9 investigation at
Harvard which I think was actually a
grave miscarriage of justice and it's
hard to avoid the suspicion that if
Roland's research had arrived at more
politically correct conclusions that
were more compatible with progressive
narratives perhaps that might not have
happened I certainly think that there is
something to be asked some hard
questions to be asked about why an
african-american professor who started
life than the wrong side of the tracks
in Texas whose first-hand experience and
experiences of police brutality why he
should have ended up being treated in
this way by mostly white progressive
administrators at the country's most
well-known and eminent university it's
something that's been on my mind for
some time now since the case against him
was brought and I sense that ultimately
we won't really be able to arrive at a
serious discussion of these issues data
based and also based on personal
experience as long as Roland has been
cancelled in the name of me too so in a
weird way do you need the institutions
to crumble so that something better can
happen like it seems like we're sort of
just in a slow crumble phase right now
they're done you know there doesn't seem
to be any great institution whether it's
Harvard or the New York Times or a
series of other things that we sort of
all look to as the the guardians of the
republic they're all sort of crumbling
do you think they have to crumble to
reset or do you think they can actually
we just reput together just put together
the pieces again
well I think that one of the lessons of
American history is that at its best the
United States creates new institutions
rather than just gives the old ones
makeovers I think one of the sad
features of our time is that the great
plutocrats of our Gilded Age have not
created new universities as their
predecessors did in the late 19th
century but but have simply given money
to the existing institutions in
particular to institutions that already
had tons of money and my recommendation
to today's robber barons or if you want
to put it politely Titans of Silicon
Valley and Wall Street is just remember
the examples of the Carnegie's and do
some innovation here build some new
institutions you don't like what's
happening at Harvard or Yale or Stanford
walk there's nothing to stop you
creating a new institution because
that's the American Way
what talk feel notice the great French
political theorist Alexis de Tocqueville
when he came to the United States before
writing his great book democracy in
America was that Americans then did not
expect the government to solve their
problems they they did it through
associational life and for me the most
striking feature of this American story
is this readiness for people at the
local level to deal with problems
locally to build civic institutions
locally and not to expect the federal
government all for that matter Harvard
of the new york times to to come up with
solutions so I desperately feel a need
for new institutions and not only at the
level of colleges I think we need new
schools there's been some innovation in
that direction in the charter school
movement but it's still really a drop in
the bucket of what needs to happen to
improve American secondary education
which is the real weakness that this
this country's is earned with so I I
think we just need to remind ourselves
that in its original
design the United States was supposed to
be a decentralized Whitby small
government see a vibrant associational
life and religious life and crucially a
sort of constant formation of new
institutions that that was what you did
if you'd been successful if you'd had
the American capitalists dream giving
back involved more than just a new
building at Harvard with your name on it
giving back meant a new University
something that hadn't existed before
that's what we seem to have lost and I'm
I'm really struck by that lack of new
institutions as one of the pathologies
one of the signs of our recent
degeneration so you don't think that the
Harvard endowment which is worth what 40
billion dollars you don't you don't
think they need a couple more bucks
well Bobby for me to advise America's
philanthropists where they should put
their money but if they applied the kind
of due diligence standards that they
apply when they're making investments to
their philanthropy then I think they
might they might at least think twice
because the return of an investment that
you get from donating to an already
established institution just can't be
that high I mean what real marginal
impact does a does a million dollars
make to Harvard whereas if you if you
were to use the money to create
something new there the return on
investment would potentially be far
higher so I I think there's a need for
for new institutions I think it would
help revitalize just as we should have
new statues if you don't like the old
ones why not build some new statues
rather than wasting your energies on on
vandalism one of my favorites sculptors
sandy Stoddart who's a great opponent of
iconoclasm built two wonderful created
two wonderful statues in Edinburgh the
Scottish capital one is of David Hume
and the other is of Adam Smith they're
beautiful statues they stand in the
Royal Mile tourists assume they've been
there for at least a hundred years
barely ten years old and I think sandy
Stoddart could be well employed in the
United States creating some beautiful
new statues
to whoever it is that we think should be
the heroes of our time that would be a
far better employments of public energy
than the kind of vandalism that we see
these days so since this is our July 4th
week show and I've got a noted historian
on give me give me a little American
history that maybe the average person
watching this give me something an
anecdote a story a moment that that the
average person watching this maybe
doesn't know that much about that they
should know is there something that
sticks out to you as why more people
should know about that story that moment
well I suspect in a crowded field
I'd be bound to choose one of those
episodes that really paved the way for
the United States have become not just a
hugely successful Republic more
successful than any previous Republic
but a great power even a superpower and
the temptation for Republic's
historically has always been at a
certain point for the The Temptations
power to steer the Republic to tyranny
this very nearly happened during Harry
Truman's presidency at the time of the
Korean War when a Rick figure Douglas
MacArthur quarreled with Truman about
the direction of the Korean War
MacArthur actually was in favor of
dropping atomic bombs on China
to end the war and it came to a clash
that to another Republic that might have
been fatal think of the fate of the
Roman Republic which ultimately became
an empire as the mighty figure of of
Augustus ultimately sucked the life out
of the institutions of the Republic but
I think that the showdown that happened
then between Truman and MacArthur
Truman's successful assertion of the
primacy of the civilian Authority
is a hugely important moment in American
history Truman was a great president in
a whole range of of ways he is best
known for the famous line the buck stops
here but it stopped there in in a very
important way when Truman asserted the
primacy of the presidency against a
charismatic military figure who when he
returned to the United States and a
ticker tape parade in New York you
watched the scenes of MacArthur's return
at that time of crisis when it seemed he
might make a presidential bid himself
you realized that the United States was
teetering on the brink of a Roman
outcome but pulled back and I I want to
emphasize that episode which isn't well
known because you should always keep in
mind the history of what hasn't happened
what didn't happen even if it nearly did
you have to keep alive in your mind all
the times that this Republic might have
have fallen from the path of democracy
and the rule of law and and remind
yourself when you were feeling down as
some people occasionally do feel down
contemplating our politics that American
democracy has never been a fairy story
when Charles Dickens came to the United
States in the 19th century he was
appalled by the viciousness of American
politics by its venality by the rule of
money by the corrupt press we shouldn't
tell ourselves that there's some golden
age in the past that we've somehow
lapsed from I think that's a very common
failing that Americans have they're
always just telling themselves it was so
much better than those good old days
pick a decade the 50s the 80s but I
don't think that's the right way to
think about American history I think
it's better to realize that the
Republican experiment the experiment
with this particular Constitution was
always going to be fraught with peril
but the founding fathers knew that
somebody like Donald Trump would become
president at some point that was why
they designed the Constitution the way
they did Alexander Hamilton is very
explicit about that in the Federalist
Papers and elsewhere so I think if as an
immigrant
my advice to Americans is don't have
this fantasy America that you keep
failing to live up to that you feel
you've somehow missed because it never
existed there's never been that fantasy
America there's always been an America
teetering on the brink with the
separation of powers threatening at
times to collapse and as I've said with
the temptations of Empire periodically
coming along and saying to the Republic
come on be Rome and thus far we've
always rightly said no you're hopeful my
friend oh yeah our that's why we come
here remember for all that Americans
love to hate on themselves this is still
the number one destination for people
who say they would like to leave the
country of their birth and it seems
unlikely to me that that would be the
case if this really was the cesspit of
of racism that it's so often described
by a described as by progressives right
I love the the open borders crowd will
also tell you that we're an evil racist
patriarchal society and yet everyone
apparently should come here
to share in the horror it's a it is a it
is a paradox one thing that curved 19
has done has been to remind everybody
that borders matter and the health and
safety of citizens in fact depend on
secure borders where people coming even
only as visitors can be monitored and
that that I think is one of important
and unexpected consequences of the
pandemic that that isn't widely
recognized ultimately president Trump's
arguments back in 2016 included the
following that borders really mattered
and shouldn't be porous and that China
was a problem and a threat to our
national security
covered by Tina's Illustrated both those
points pretty well and here we are
dare I ask a historian to make some
political predictions go on I the only
point of studying history is to
understand the present and plausible
futures better
so are you gonna punt that one I mean
what do you think's gonna happen over
there if you had to just sort of
generally paint the next couple months
where do you think we're at I think
what's going to happen is what happened
in 2016 that opinion polls and approval
ratings will consistently predict a
democratic victory and the media and the
people who work on on American politics
will replicate the mistakes that they
made in 2016 by looking ever more
closely at polls and and prediction
markets and and and then they will get a
very very big surprise because I end
from revealed preferences as opposed to
stated preferences that the country is
far from convinced that it should go
down the road of open borders or
defunding the police or a green new deal
and the more they hear of those radical
ideas from Democrats the more upheaval
they see in the streets of American
cities the more they quietly make a
mental notes to votes to vote Republican
on November the third but of course I
could find myself very badly wrong
anybody who makes a prediction about
American election in the summer is is
running the risk of of engaging in a
kind of astrology but let me give you a
data point Dave it's very interesting
and I've heard it from many different
quarters how many people have bought
firearms in 2020 in the monthly auction
we were looking at one of them and
you're looking at one of them too David
in the month of March alone the the
monthly background checks were double
what happened on average in 2019 now I'm
going to call that a revealed preference
and I'm going to suggest that the months
of May and June may also see elevated
purchases one of the most sure
predictors of a Republican vote in 2016
was if a household possessed a firearm
households without firearms
overwhelmingly voted Democrat houses
with
overwhelmingly voted Republican I'm just
saying that there are sources of data
other than opinion polls that it would
be prudent to look at at a time when
people have all kinds of incentives not
to be quite straight with pollsters
revealed preferences other things to
look at and my sense is that the mood of
the country is not being well understood
by the New York Times or The Washington
Post or CNN at the moment I don't think
it's been well understood at all my
nightmare though to take another stab at
prediction is that we end up with a
result like mm that we end up with a tie
I worry that that Joe Biden's our weak
candidate and Donald Trump is in a
recession having not handled covered 19
brilliantly they're both weak and in
that scenario you could imagine a 2,000
light result but with multiple states
having their results contested because
of controversies around a postal voting
and and that would be the nightmare
scenario for the United States because
it would not be resolved as quickly as
it was nor would the result be accepted
by the losing side as quickly as it was
in 2000 so when I look into the crystal
ball I do find myself hoping for a
decisive result because a tie of that
sort I think would plunge us into weeks
possibly months of strife and it would
be the perfect opportunity for America's
enemies to make any move that they might
have been considering all right we can't
end on this because you've actually been
quite uplifting throughout and have a
firm belief in America so you got to
bring me home on something positive give
it give me something here to bring it
all together well I think as I said
worrying about this stuff is probably
the best way to prepare for it and avert
a disaster there's still time actually
to make sure that we don't have multiple
contested results from States it's as we
speak
not yet July 4th in the same way looking
back that we can learn from what went
wrong in this country in January and
February remember the real question for
2020 is not
present Trump get covered 19 wrong the
real question is why'd the Department of
Health and Human Services which has an
assistant secretary for preparedness get
it wrong why did what we sometimes
called a deep state fail so disastrously
to get this right despite on paper
having multiple plans for pandemic
preparedness and bio defense so I think
we have the chance now to start learning
from mistakes that were made back in
January when we could have averted this
great economic catastrophe just by
learning from what the Taiwanese and the
South Koreans did we still I think have
the ability I don't think we've so lost
our minds that we've lost the ability to
learn from obvious mistakes of
governance and we should learn from what
went wrong in that pandemic just as we
should learn from what went wrong in
some recent elections
I mean think of some of the primary
results that descended into farce we've
got to make sure by worrying about this
issue that we don't have me an Iowa
caucus writ large on November the third
you can imagine you understand the
internet as well as any public
intellectual Dave you can imagine the
chaos of conspiracy theories we could be
confronting on November the fourth if
there is uncertainty so you know let's
do what Americans have long been famous
for here's a problem let's fix it with
the can-do spirit that's what Europeans
used to say distinguished Americans from
everybody else let's fix the problems
that have revealed themselves in our
pandemic preparedness and in our
electoral system we've just got time to
do it and it will be I think the perfect
expression of the American Way if we fix
it just in time if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists there all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell